gebäude in dünner und flüssiger hülle
gebäude trotzen dem klimawandel in jener
arbeiten experten an den bauelementen
der zukunft jetzt in klicks um
science-fiction also gebäude in dünner
und flüssiger hülle schwimmende häuser
das klingt nach fiktion aber an solchen
entwicklung wird tatsächlich gearbeitet
denn wir werden uns in zukunft anpassen
müssen und vor allen dingen der zukunft
anpassen müssen die welt verändert sich
am laufenden band das klima verändert
sich der lebensraum wird vieles weniger
und immer schwieriger zu erschließen die
vorherrschenden temperaturen und die
damit verbundenen umwelteinflüsse
spielen eine immer größere rolle
in den niederlanden hat man schon früh
mit einer auf die umwelt angepassten
architektur begonnen iburg ist einer der
besonderen stadtteile von amsterdam auf
dem größten binnensee des landes liegt
der stadtteil und zugleich auch das
varta wohnungen projekt der name verrät
es ja schon auf dem wasser wohnen mehr
als 50 häuser villen und mehrstöckige
mietshäuser schwimmen dort auf dem
wasser das unternehmen weiter studio nl
war an dem spektakulären bauvorhaben
beteiligt könne all tui von wörter
studie weiter studien l äußert sich zu
dem projekt so wir wollten zeigen dass
man nicht nur hausboote bauen kann
sondern richtige häuser die schwimmen
erreicht wurde das mit extra
konzipierten fundamenten bestehend aus
styropor das mit einem spezialbeton
ummantelt ist diese können frei
aneinander gebaut werden und würden bis
zu einer seitenlänge von 200 meter einen
stabilen untergrund bilden wäre nicht
2013 die finanzkrise ausgebrochen
könnten vermutlich schon heute resultate
des new water project zu sehen sein ziel
des new water projekts waren immerhin
600 schwimmende wohnhäuser experten
zufolge wird der meeresspiegel in den
nächsten 85 jahren über einen meter
ansteigen immer höhere und breitere
deichbauten helfen nicht so
klimaforscher pavel karat von der
universität wagen zügen in den
niederlanden eine der renommiertesten
universitäten im bereich der wasser
stadtplanung die tu delft und viele
andere universitäten arbeiten auf
hochtouren um lösungen zu finden
die sogenannte delta kommission kostet
die niederlande in etwa 1 2 milliarden
euro im jahr dieses geld wird eingesetzt
um den wissenschaftlichen fortschritt in
die tat umzusetzen
vor zehn jahren gab das ministerium für
stadtplanung und wohnen ganze 15 gebiete
frei um den forschern platz für die
praxis
zu schaffen in diesen gebieten dürfen
die experten ihre projekte testen und
verwirklichen wie beispielsweise im
ibook die 1 2 milliarden euro könnten
sich schon bald auch deshalb für die
niederlande auszahlen die philippinen
beispielsweise sind von den gefahren
durch überflutungen stark bedroht in
etwa 14 millionen filipinos würden laut
der climate change kongress auf philipp
heinz organisationen die folgen des
klimawandels überschwemmungen zu spüren
bekommen was man in amsterdam konzipiert
soll in den philippinen leben retten in
jena wächst währenddessen eine
multifunktionale hausfassade heran die
in ländern mit extremen
temperaturschwankungen von großem nutzen
sein könnte
die dort entwickelte technologie soll
den wohnraum innerhalb eines gebäudes
sowohl kühl als auch warm halten können
wird es im sommer also extrem heiß
bleibt es im inneren erträglich und
fallen die temperaturen in den
wintermonaten stark ab müssen keine
größe großen mühen betrieben werden um
den komplex warm zu halten mittel zum
zweck eine dünne und flüssige hülle in
der forschungs meldung der friedrich
schiller universität jena heißt es zitat
die flüssigkeit dienen dabei zunächst
als puffer und speichermedium für wärme
kann darüber hinaus aber auch weitere
funktionen wie zum beispiel einen
farbwechsel oder solarthermischen
wärmeaustausch übernehmen konkret sieht
das konzept der jenaer forscher so aus
dass glas module von der dicke einer
normalen fensterscheibe mit dünnen
kanälen versehen werden durch die eine
farblose speicher flüssigkeit auf
wasserbasis flieht zitat ende sowohl in
computersimulationen als auch in der
bohrtests konnte man die funktionalität
unter beweis stellen es funktionierte
und wäre dabei auch noch einfach
anzubringen zitat die module lassen sich
einerseits als fensterverglasung
einsetzen wofür eine möglichst geringe
sichtbarkeit der kanal strukturen
entscheidend ist andererseits können sie
direkt in gebäudefassaden integriert
werden so professor wondracek über die
neuen bauelemente die im fachmagazin
advanced science veröffentlichte
forschungsarbeit kann man zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt vielleicht nicht mit dem new
yorker projekt auf eine ebene stellen da
sie gerade vor allem energetische
aspekte in den vordergrund stellt aber
energie ist ein großer faktor in
krisengebieten startet man in diesen
regionen sämtliche medizinischen
einrichtungen zum beispiel mit solchen
multifunktionalen
schaden aus würde viel energie gespart
werden die anderweitig eingesetzt werden
könnte wie seht ihr das werden wir uns
weiter in diese richtung entwickeln wird
es mehr solche empfindungen geben lass
mir eure meinung dazu da in den
kommentaren und stark mal vor welche
ideen ihr noch habt also lasst uns
diskutieren in den kommentaren und wenn
euch das video gefallen hat lass mir
gerne einen daumen nach oben da und ein
kostenloses abo einfach anklicken und
wenn er hier klickt kommt ihr zu einem
video in dem wir uns mal mit dem tag an
dem die erde verbraucht ist beschäftigt
haben ja ein
auch schlimmes thema eigentlich
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran